[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend dass sich die verbreitung von
elektroautos hierzulande bislang noch
sehr in grenzen hält hat natürlich
verschiedene gründe
die hohen preise die der aufgerufen
werden spielen eine rolle
aber viele potenzielle käufer schreckt
auch das lade probleme ab so gibt es
inzwischen zumindest der großstädten
oder an autobahnraststätten mehr
ladepunkte und für bestimmte batterie
und fahrzeugtypen auch
schnellladestationen aber insgesamt ist
die infrastruktur für elektroautos immer
noch bau die bundesregierung will das
nun vorantreiben und die industrie
stärker in die pflicht nehmen
am montag gibt es dazu ein
spitzengespräch im kanzleramt christian
hübscher berichtet übermorgen geht
dieses vollelektrische auto in serie der
volkswagen id3 soll den elektro
automarkt in deutschland endlich
massentauglich machen
da fällt der bundesregierung auf es gibt
doch gar nicht genügend
lademöglichkeiten höchste zeit für den
verkehrsminister nicht weniger als einen
masterplan ladeinfrastruktur zu
schreiben
das auto immer und überall laden zu
können sei ein wichtiger hebel für die
kaufentscheidung hat die bundesregierung
erkannt
reichlich spät kommentiert die
opposition die erkenntnis dass man da
mehr tun muss
die ist gut aber die kommt zu spät wir
haben internationalen stück weit den
anschluss verloren
deutschland hinkt auch hinter anderen
europäischen ländern hinterher
schon bald soll nun eine solche wall box
also eine ladebox für die wand in vielen
deutschen privat garagen hängen
es gibt sie ab 500 euro und die
bundesregierung will künftig jedem
käufer geld dazugeben
da geht es aber auch darum politische
rahmenbedingungen zu setzen von der
steuergesetzgebung bis zum
wohnungseigentum stichwort ladesäulen in
tiefgaragen von mehrfamilienhäusern
geht es nach andreas scheuer müssen
vermieter ihren mietern künftig den
einbau einer solchen privaten
ladestation erlauben bis es für alle
soweit ist soll man sein auto zum
beispiel auch nachts auf supermarkt
plätzen laden dürfen im öffentlichen
raum werden laut entwurf an allen
autobahnen und fernstraßen zuerst 1000
neue schnelllade
punkte gefördert bis 2030 soll es dann
ein lückenloses ladenetz in ganz
deutschland geben auch tankstellen
sollen strom verkaufen dürfen unklar
aber wer ist der betreiber all der
ladesäulen und wie könnte eine einfache
und einheitliche bezahlung aussehen
das problem ist dass es kein
geschäftsmodell gibt bei den ladesäulen
die einen rechnen nach zeit ab die
andere nach kilowattstunde
und das ist auch eines der kernprobleme
wer das ganze wie betragen soll
die energiewirtschaft ist grundsätzlich
bereit den bagger rauszuholen und zu
investieren sowie in baden württemberg
schon flächendeckend passiert im auto
ländle steht bereits alle zehn kilometer
eine ladesäule aufgestellt von einem
konsortium aus kommunen und wirtschaft
doch die unsicherheit bleibt die leute
die die lade infrastruktur bereitstellen
sollen müssen auch in der lage sein dass
irgendwo finanziell abzubilden heißt für
mich im klartext so wie es die
ladeinfrastruktur braucht braucht es die
fahrzeuge die sie auch nutzen in einer
auskömmlichen zahl die erfahrungen
zeigen dass wenn die infrastruktur
vorhanden ist die menschen auch
umsteigen
das eine war die reichweite da ist
gerade die automobilindustrie bei das
deutlich zu verlängern und das zweite
war die sorge irgendwo liegen zu bleiben
und keine ladestation zu finden und wenn
du beides ausräumen dann wird auch die
attraktivität der elektromobilität
steigen das henne-ei-problem die
bundesregierung hofft bis 2030 auf 7 bis
10 millionen elektroautos in deutschland
am montag wird der verkehrsminister
seinen plan mit kanzlerin merkel und den
chefs der automobilindustrie diskutieren
in einer ganzen reihe
lateinamerikanischer länder gibt es
derzeit unruhen in venezuela ja sowieso
aber auch in ecuador bolivien und chile
chile unterscheidet sich von den anderen
weil es vergleichsweise wohlhabend
modern und sicher ist
doch hinter dieser fassade brodelt es
auch dort schon seit langem bürgerliche
schichten mit wachsendem
selbstbewusstsein und viele gut
ausgebildete junge menschen sind immer
weniger bereit die extrem ungleiche
wohlstandsverteilung in dem land hin zu
nehmen
seit jahren wächst der widerstand gegen
eine wirtschaftspolitik die radikal
markt und privatisierung setzt kaum
soziale sicherheit dafür hohe
lebenshaltungskosten die familien
belasten studenten regelrecht in den
ruin treiben
der unmut darüber bericht sich nun bei
seit wochen gibt es massenproteste teils
mit heftigen ausschreitungen
unser korrespondent christoph bröcker
rat es denn santiago und erlebt eine
stadt in aufruhr das blech unter der
isolation des alten kühlschranks bringt
geld zumindest ein wenig eine wilde
müllkippe im stadtpark von santiago de
chile
lange müssen wir nicht suchen nach
solchen bildern und schicksal ganz unten
ist zurzeit an vielen stellen und chiles
hauptstadt korn ist 75 jahre alt und
investiert das bisschen seiner rente in
gemüse um es zu verkaufen sein gemüse
ist welt sein ausblick aufs leben trüb
die meisten rentner bekommen viel zu
wenig dabei machen wir ein fünftel der
bevölkerung aus und wir müssen alles
selbst bezahlen vor allem medikamente
und die miete denn kaum jemand hat eine
eigene wohnung oder ein haus
doch hohe ins kritik an der politik
bleibt nicht lange unwidersprochen ein
anderer rentner gibt die schuld an
seiner ebenfalls schlechten lage den
früheren linken regierungen
das waren doch alles verbrecher unser
jetziger präsident ist ein guter mann
sofort entwickelt sich eine lebhafte
diskussion was der redet hat nichts mit
der realität zu tun
das ist alles quatsch das sehen wir hier
überall die stimmung ist unglaublich
gereizt wenn unsere kamera irgendwo
auftaucht die einen klagen über die
regierung dann kommen andere wie der
herr gerade die sagen die regierung ist
super dass alles eine kommunistische
verschwörung so eine sehr
unübersichtliche und sehr gereizte
stimmung hier in santiago präsident
pinera muss weg bruder wie gereizt die
stimmung ist das sollten wir später noch
am eigenen leib erfahren
zunächst aber beginnen die
demonstrationen des tages friedlich
frauen marschieren mit verbundenen augen
solidarität mit ihnen die durch
gummigeschosse der polizei ihr
augenlicht verloren haben mehr als 1300
demonstranten wurden bislang verletzt
mindestens 20 kamen ums leben
chile gilt als modernes reiches land
doch die liberale wirtschaftspolitik und
drastische privatisierungen haben
millionen menschen abgehängt
seit wochen demonstrieren sie gegen hohe
lebenshaltungskosten niedrige löhne und
renten gegen die wachsende soziale
ungleichheit
wir wollen unsere würde zurück unsere
demokratie stirbt weil sie dem
neoliberalismus geopfert wird
die menschen verlieren ihre freiheit
kurz darauf kommt es zu gewalt von
beiden seiten wenige augenblicke nachdem
wir diese bilder gedreht haben wendet
sich die aggression direkt gegen uns
irgendwer ruft wir seien die lügen der
chilenische presse der regierung
schlagartig werden wir brutal
angegriffen müssen flüchten
wir sind gerade von einer immer größer
werdenden gruppe von demonstranten
massiv angegriffen wurden wir würden
geschlagen
unsere ausrüstung wurde beschädigt man
wollte uns die kamera weg reißen und wir
mussten tatsächlich rennen steine flogen
hinter uns her es wurde mit
steinschleudern auf uns geschossen
wir hatten ein riesenglück und erst als
wir hier bei diesen fahrzeugen
angekommen sind hat der mob hat diese
wütender masse von uns abgelassen ist
zeigt wie aggressiv die stimmung
inzwischen ist selbst der presse
gegenüber ein paar demonstranten wollen
sich erklären
er hätte sagen müssen dass ihr ausländer
seit nicht einheimische presse als ob
das eine entschuldigung wäre immerhin
sie haben dann doch noch mit uns geredet
mehr hintergründe und videos zu den
unruhen chile finden sie online auf
erstmal die nachrichten von hans wolfen
die beginnen mit der indien reise von
kanzlerin merkel heute war der zweite
und letzte tag dieses besuchs in indien
bei dem es unter anderem um stärkere
wirtschaftsbeziehungen ging so sprach
sich die bundeskanzlerin in einer rede
vor der deutsch indischen handelskammer
für ein freihandelsabkommen zwischen der
eu und indien aus gestern hatte merkel
bereits mit ministerpräsident modi
gesprochen deutschland und indien wollen
auch beim klimaschutz und bei
zukunftsthemen wie künstliche
intelligenz und digitalisierung enger
zusammenarbeiten
die ehemaligen grünen chefs cem özdemir
und claudia roth stehen offenbar auf
einer todesliste von rechtsextremisten
die grünen bundestagsfraktion bestätigte
dem zdf dass es solche morddrohungen
gegen beide gibt absender soll der
deutsche ableger einer
rechtsextremistischen gruppe aus den usa
sein
im süden von mali sind bei einem
überfall auf einen armeestützpunkt
mindestens 54 soldaten getötet worden
die terror medizin es hört sich zu der
tat bekannt vor rund einem monat hat
mutmaßliche islamisten bei überfällen
auf zwei armee stützpunkte in anderen
regionen des landes 40 soldaten getötet
in mali beteiligen sich auch bis zu 1100
bundeswehrsoldaten an einem un
stabilisierungseinsatz sowie an der
ausbildung malischer soldaten in
hongkong sind heute wieder
regierungskritische demonstranten auf
die straße gegangen dabei kam es auch
wieder zu ausschreitungen
dutzende aktivisten wurden festgenommen
die proteste dauern nun schon rund fünf
monate an
die demonstranten fordern mehr
demokratische freiheiten und weniger
einfluss pekings zudem wollen sie
untersuchungen zur polizeigewalt sowie
die freilassung der festgenommenen
durchsetzen
ziemlich spektakuläre spiele gab es
heute in der bundesliga mit denen
beschäftigt sich gleich noch das
aktuelle sportstudio
in berlin etwa das stadtderby union
gegen hertha aber auch in den unteren
ligen bei den amateuren wurde in berlin
gespielt was nicht mehr
selbstverständlich ist
letztes wochenende fielen in berlin rund
1500 fußballspiele aus weil die
schiedsrichter zu hause blieben aus
protest weil sie verständlicherweise
keine lust mehr haben sich anpöbeln oder
gar verprügeln zu lassen das problem
gibt es nicht nur in berlin
er ist das wochenende musste bei einem
kreisligaspiel in hessen ein
schiedsrichter per rettungshubschrauber
ins krankenhaus gebracht werden
eine verrohung der sitten die sich auch
in anderen gesellschaftlichen bereichen
findet romanesco war berichtet
es wird wieder gespielt in berlins
amateurfußball nachdem schiedsrichter
streik sind es die ersten punktspiele
die referees hoffen auf einen neustart
der ausstand war eine aktion gedacht als
weckruf nach einer entwicklung bei der
man nicht mehr zu sehen wollte in
unserer höchsten spielklasse gab es zwei
körperliche gewaltakte gegen
schiedsrichter in den unteren
spielklassen es ist geradezu am alltag
dass jedes wochenende irgendein spiel
abgebrochen wird weil das gewalt gegen
den schiedsrichter gibt und dann ist
irgendwann auch mal das maß voll
während berlin streit eskalierte die
situation in südhessen der faustschlag
eines spielers nach einer roten karte
heizte die debatte weiter an
ein besonders drastisches beispiel
insgesamt belegen studien keinen
deutlichen anstieg an gewaltvorfällen
was aber immer mehr an leidet ist der
respekt beklagen selbst die jüngsten
schon beleidigungen pöbeleien für jascha
wörter er alltag als ausnahme 16 jahre
alt ist er leitet oft partien beim
nachwuchs hier sind es weniger spieler
sondern trainer und vor allem eltern die
trotz seines alters verbal keine grenzen
kennen
linde sei wenn es ganz schön wird auch
[ __ ] das sind halt so die
alltäglichen beleidigung die auch in der
gesellschaft vielleicht mal ab und zu
vorkommen die sich natürlich auch aufs
fußballfeld daran übertragen und die wir
uns anhören müssen
der berliner fußball-verband versucht
auch mit kampagnen gegenzusteuern ein
schwieriges unterfangen eltern
spielertrainer gleichermaßen zu
erreichen
nun allerdings soll es nicht bei
appellen bleiben nicht zuletzt durch die
aktuelle diskussion sind konkrete
maßnahmen geplant also einmal wird es um
den schutz der schiedsrichter gehen
durch gestellung von ordnern dass er für
die vereine verpflichtend gemacht
während der zweite punkt wird sein dass
wir versuchen in den nächsten jahren die
qualifizierung unser trainer
voranzubringen dass wir jetzt
verpflichten für alle spiele machen und
wir überprüfen gegenwärtig die
rechtsordnung ob das strafmaß
ausreichend ist für den amateurfußball
sind es insgesamt keine leichten zeiten
gestern traf man sich in berlin zum
nachmittag für den fußball und das
ehrenamt ein amt dass immer weniger
übernehmen wollen für die vereine wird
es dadurch nicht leichter
die probleme anzugehen
teilweise und desinteresse teilweise
auch sieht man bei den kleineren und bei
den nachwuchs schon die eltern kinder
keine vereinsarbeit mehr oder
vereinszugehörigkeit mir das ist aber
auch schwer die ehrenamtler die man
schon lange in seinen eigenen reihen hat
immer wieder neu zu motivieren für neue
aufträge zu begeistern langfristige
projekte gemeinsam anzugehen ich weiß
vereine die eigentlich überhaupt gar
keine leute mir finden und die im
prinzip kurz davor sind zu sterben oder
schon gestorben sind große
herausforderungen warten also im
amateurbereich will der fußball vorbild
und nicht nur spiegelbild der
gesellschaft sein
der schweizer schriftsteller lukas
bärfuss hat heute den georg büchner
preis erhalten
für die jury ist der 47 jährige einer
der herausragenden erzähler und
dramatiker der deutschsprachigen
gegenwartsliteratur bärfuss sagte in
seiner dankesrede sein werk sei in
weiten teilen ein zeugnis für die
menschliche niedertracht und grausamkeit
der büchner preis gilt als wichtigste
literarische auszeichnung in deutschland
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
6 15 17 21 25 41 superzahl 3 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und dem zdf text auf seite 55 6
die wetteraussichten für morgen
wechselnd oder stark bewölkt und
zeitweise regen
lebhafter wind aus südlichen richtungen
höchstwerte 11 bis 15 grad
und auch in den nächsten tagen
unbeständig immer wieder regen
dazwischen aber auch etwas sonne und
allmählich wieder kälter ja stadtderby
in berlin und das sensation spiel der
eintracht gegen die bayern reichlich
stoff das sportstudio und dahin geben
wir jetzt weiter doch mit dem kurzen
hinweis dass es danach die nächste heute
express gibt zu gegen 0.25 bis morgen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]